depuis fin janvier il était impossible
de franchir les frontières belges sans
motif impérieux en raison de la pandémie
une interdiction arrivée à son terme
dimanche soir les déplacements depuis et
vers l'étranger reste déconseillé par
les autorités mais les belges peuvent à
nouveau se rendre dans les aéroports ou
les gares pour voyager au sein de
l'union européenne à moi je suis très
heureux parce que ma petite fille arrive
antalis de paris et je ne les plus vus
depuis trop longtemps avec ce
confinement et donc c'est une très très
bonne chose ça permet pas de pouvoir
profiter tout en étant dans les règles
et en essayant de limiter un maximum la
propagation du président pour laisser le
temps à la population d'être vacciné les
cafés et restaurants fermés depuis
octobre n'ouvriront pas leurs terrasses
avant le 8 mai c'est aussi le retour à
l'école pour les belges ce lundi les
vacances de pâques sont terminés une
semaine avant qu'elles ne commencent
seules les écoles maternelles étaient
ouvertes même assouplissement au
portugal entrez dans la troisième phase
d'un déconfinement progressif commencé
il y à plus d'un mois résultat les
lycées et les universités ouvrent leurs
portes tout comme les centres
commerciaux les cafés et restaurants
accueillent des clients mais avec un
nombre limité et des horaires restreints
cela me manquait déjà je vais bientôt
partir en voyage à l'étranger
donc je dois acheter des vêtements cette
réouverture arrive au bon moment on ne
peut pas voyager sans vêtements
de plus ça me manque aussi de pouvoir
m'asseoir et prendre un café et quelque
chose à manger on se remet au boulot on
a nos clients qui arrivent on remet la
maison en marche car cela fait trois
mois que l'on était fermée sans rien
pouvoir faire
on espère que cela va durer on va tout
faire pour c'est important d'avoir pu
réussir à arriver jusqu'ici
on va voir ce que le futur nous réserve
ce n'est pas impossible que l'on doive
confiné mais nous ne devons pas tomber
dans une joie excessive et les gens
doivent continuer à se comporter
raisonnablement
les salles de spectacle et les cinémas
reprennent aussi leurs activités le
portugal a vécu un confinement national
de deux mois pour endiguer une
importante troisième vague épidémique
ils avancent petit à petit vers un
retour à la vie normale
dernière étape de ce déconfinement le 3
mai